New Year's just 12 days old and the
White House is in serious damage control
mode the challenges go far beyond the
presidents reported crude remark
yesterday there's also the charges in
Michael Wolf's tell-all book fire and
fury the confusion over his view of daca
and a federal surveillance program and
the upcoming retirements of Republicans
in Congress CBS News political
contributor Bob Schieffer
has covered nine presidents over his
career Bob good morning good morning to
you it's great to see you get along with
just one face in Asia
there is just one next phase the nation
host and I'm at glad to ask him a
question Bob let's start with these
comments about immigration take it away
well they did not remind me of George
Washington or any of his other
predecessors I can't imagine I mean look
we all know these words I mean anybody
that's been in a control room at a
television studio when something goes
wrong you learn a lot of new words and
so this is nothing but to say this in
the White House during a discussion
office yeah this is a new law and I
think he ought to be ashamed of himself
now do I understand he's now saying he
didn't say it is there a new tweet and
that's what that's what he's saying of
course there are multiple people who
were in the meeting who said in the
White House didn't didn't deny it
yeah they tried to turn it into some
kind of a view about his toughness on
immigration but they didn't deny he said
it but Bob what about the fact that he
called them excellent whole countries
when he was referring to countries that
have a predominantly black population
and said why couldn't we get people here
from Norway which is 99 percent white
and all who report they're very happy in
Norway which is what I mean there there
was a show the other day in Norway so
this is is it racist yeah yeah I mean
how can you take it any other way and
and and I said when I say that I don't
say that lightly but I mean how else
could one read this and you know this
should not be a bipartisan issue the
fact that it was so hurtful and so
unkind and just so demeaning to so many
people are you surprised that more
Republicans aren't really speaking up
and just really condemning those words I
am in some ways but I mean you know
that's their business I have I have my
opinions and they have theirs but I
don't see how this helps them or anyone
else and I don't know where this goes I
mean this was the most unusual campaign
we've ever experienced certainly in my
lifetime this year with the coming of
the the wolf book the chaos rolls on so
learn anything in that book that you
didn't know or what do you your thoughts
about that book you know I think he
really nailed the chaos in the White
House and I think he was right on now
you know you can question some of his
sources and methods and all of that but
people always have asked me over the
years what's your favorite beat the
White House I guess and I say yeah that
was fun but you know everybody in the
White House they all work for the same
guy it's on Capitol Hill where you've
really find news because there are all
these factions and there are all these
different independent contractors and
that's what's fun for a reporter but
that's really not apt anymore and as the
book the wolf book underlined there is
many factions in the White House now as
there are up on Capitol Hill and we've
never had anything like that before and
I thought he really gave you a guide I
mean you had the Spicer and the Priebus
wing over here it's kind of speaking for
establishment Republicans you have baman
there's this whole new force into
himself over here you have the cushion
her family they had their own spokesmen
they had their own agenda and then you
had the boys the Trump boys over here in
all of these people I mean there's no
question about it they're all leaking
their old
have their own agendas we've never had
anything like that get kind of your
historical perspective too on
questioning the fitness of the president
the mental fitness of the president you
know I don't know I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna say I'm not a doctor and I I don't
know what it what it is but I do say I
keep one green why does he say these
things why why does he step on his own
story when you're in the middle of the
the tax reform and all of that and he
has the little good news and he manages
to get something else some of this stuff
involved in it I don't know why he does
what he does and these most recent
contact comments come into context
remember he started his campaign saying
Mexicans are rapists so yeah this is not
the first time you said this what do you
think the effect will be for Republicans
running in 2018 of the president you
know I think the story the most
underreported story right now and the
reason we haven't reported on it is
simply because you have all these
disasters that we're going through with
the climate at the same time this
continuing ongoing chaos in the White
House I'm beginning to think for the
first time that there is a check I think
the Democrats may actually take the
house this time you've had 29
Republicans now that have decided
they're not going to run they only need
24 seats the Democrats to take the house
I'm not saying it's gonna happen but I
think it's now possible I wouldn't say
it's probable but I think it's possible
and I think that's the big story we
haven't had time to talk about it well
and we're out of time now Bob we'll have
you back to talk about about Center
thanks